So, this is NVVP. It's a very powerful tool. It has a lot of functionality.
We're only going to touch on it today. My real point is simply to point out to
you that these tools exist and that even though in this class we're going to
focus on understanding the concepts and being able to reason about these things from scratch,
I do want you to understand that you don't have to always do this from scratch,
that you should use the tools that are available.
So the first thing we're going to do is pick an executable to run on.
And so this is where we tell it what executable to run, we're going to run our transpose code.
Before we do that, I'm actually going to go into the transpose code and comment
out the section of it that is running the transpose serial kernel,
that first kernel that we figured out. That one is so slow that I don't really want to spend any more time on that.
And as you'll see, the profiler takes a little time to run the code several times and acquire statistics about it.
So I comment that out and save it. I go back and I recompile my code, and now I'm ready to go back to NVVP,
tell it what executable we're going to run, and here we go.
It runs the program, it measures all of the calls to the CUDA API, things like malloc and memcpy,
and it measures the time taken for every kernel.
Here's the transpose parallel per row kernel. Let me zoom In on that.
You can see that the parallel per row kernel started a 110 milliseconds into the executional programs,
finished at 119 milliseconds into the program,
ran a single block at a grid size of 111 so it launched a single block,
that block had 1024 threads. You can get a bunch of other statistics from this.
If we scroll to the right, we can see the much shorter time taken by our transpose per element kernel.
I'll zoom In even further. And this one, as you see,
ran in a larger grid of 64 by 64 blocks, each of which had 16 by 16 threads.
Now, I'll make the point that we measured a shorter time than that.
And that the times that you see in the profile are not going to
match up exactly to the timings that we measured a little bit ago, when we were outside the profiler,
and that's to be expected.